hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren das hier ist Sandra
sandra hatte auf jeden Fall noch nie
eine VR Brille auf und das werden wir
heute ändern ja eine Virtual Crystal
Rock
das ist aber klar Sprachen lernen Babbel
danach spielt heute auf jeden Fall eine
Achterbahn Simulator und wir werden die
dabei jetzt mal beobachten
aber ich fahr nicht echt ne nein du
stehst ja hier steht
was habe ich denn jetzt gedrückt habe
gespielt da
ach du heilige Scheiße
ein paar Sekunden
[Musik]
was macht das denn jetzt ein Bild von
mir selber
an nein
schwindelig komisch jetzt in normalen
Menschen mir ist total schwindelig ach
du heiliger
Alter das sind so viele
mir ist total schlecht jetzt wirklich
wir schwindelig unter wassertaucher
siehst du denn auch ja die sehen auch
Weihnachtsessen
also Leute ich sehe das übrigens auch
nicht ich sehe das hier auf dem Monitor
die ganze Zeit
das sieht schon heftig real aus ne ne
erschrocken irgendwo
boah
[Musik]
bitte ich werde dich erschrocken
halt mal dein Maul hast du den
Orang-Utan gesehen Luca
du kapierst total schlecht also jetzt
noch
halt dein Maul Alter ist Sommer
also fertig ist die T-Rex Kingdom Bahn
und sie macht einen Rennen das heißt sie
muss selber die Achterbahn weißt du
überhaupt wie das geht irgendwie
rückwärts
oh oh oh oh nein schon verkackt jetzt
wieder von vorne los
[Musik]
wie bei der Fahrschule Stopp Stopp Stopp
Stopp Stopp und genau wie bei der
Fahrschule geschafft
so schlecht früher
mach das nicht
das erste Virtual Reality Brille
Erfahrung wenn ich das eventuell die
Tage noch mal machen soll dann bestell
ich mir so anstecken Mikro da kann man
auch Golfspieler kann man wandern kann
man alles mögliche machen schreibt mir
das mal gerne in die Kommentare und